un jour mon père m'a offert un tambour
malbar tambour d'origine indienne
moi j'avais déjà vu ce genre de tambours
lors des processions mais ce tambour
particulièrement c'est un mystère pour
moi
sa peau était complètement détendu et
gens venaient à croire qu'il avait été
mal construit alors je les laissais
pendant des années pourrir dans un
placard
mon père l'a même jeté un jour j'ai su
longtemps après qu'il fallait le
chauffer avec un feu pour que sa peau se
tendent et qu'il soit jouable
voilà comment on peut passer comme on
passe à côté de la beauté de l'amour de
la richesse d'une culture sans s'en
apercevoir
je vais vous parler de ma rencontre avec
le maloya le blues dernière africain
notre musique traditionnelle de ma
rencontre avec la culture de lille dans
laquelle je suis né et dans laquelle je
vis la réunion il est possible que qu'on
voit plus vraiment ces choses quand
elles sont trop souvent devant nos yeux
mes parents se sont installés à la
réunion il ya plus de 40 ans mon père a
parcouru l'île en long et en large pour
amener ce dont les gens avaient besoin
parce que les magasins manqué moi des
fois j'allais avec lui et je rencontrais
c'est gramoune ces personnes âgées qui
parle un créole plus authentique que
celui de mes camarades
j'en garde un excellent souvenir j'ai
rencontré monsieur firmin viry un des
piliers du maloya
il m'avait offert un caillou un
instrument en tiges de fleurs de cannes
ma mère elle s'occupait notre éducation
elle vivait tant bien que mal avec les
cicatrices laissées par la deuxième
guerre mondiale par les camps de
réfugiés et par le racisme
parmi toutes ces choses qui ont fait que
mes parents se sont se sont aimés sont
approchés il ya eu l'amour de la musique
l'amour du jazz mon père avait
d'ailleurs un club de jazz au havre ma
mère adore le jazz
il avait aussi l'amour de la chanson
française
l'amour des mots des chanteurs engagés
comme jacques brel brassens léo ferré
reggiani ferrat barbarin et ma mère
venait écouter avec moi souvent la
musique
elle me disait écoute carlo tu vois ce
qu'il dit là je crois qu'il veut dire
vraiment ça qu'est ce que tu crois que
tu dis moi ce que tu comprends elle me
faisait voir entre les lignes je crois
qu'on peut passer à côté des mots comme
on passe à côté des cultures moi je
crois que c'est à ce moment que l' envie
de faire de la chanson l'envi décrit
rennais j'ai toujours eu besoin
d'exprimer mes émotions
alors on m'a mis une raquette de tennis
par hasard dans la main et par hasard
j'ai tapé des balles et des bas les
débats les débats n'étaient pas jusqu'à
devenir champion de la réunion et faire
les championnats de france de roland
garros
c'est un avenir tout tracé j'avais plus
qu'à continuer et puis je me suis fait
mal au genou
je me suis blessé chance ou malchance
y a que le temps qui nous répond alors
c'est à ce moment que j'ai commencé à
écrire beaucoup dans mes dents mais
agenda où je devais écrire mes devoirs
maman tu me regardes et j'écrivais en
français mais j'écrivais j'ai écrit tout
de suite en créole aussi pourquoi parce
que le créole c'était une libération
pour moi en france il y avait le dogme
de l'orthographe et les les professeurs
ne faisait bien comprendre que on
pouvait pas prétendre aimer les mots et
mais quelle est la poésie
si on faisait des fautes d'orthographe
moi j'avais toujours moins 20 ans dictée
donc donc c'était une libération pour
moi parce qu'il n'ya pas de graphie
imposé ensuite j'ai construit mon
premier groupe de musique à cette époque
sap et caddoc et mes amis de ce groupe
et des autres sont allés en métropole à
toulouse exactement suivre une école de
musique alors moi je me suis retourné
vers mes parents je leur ai dit mais moi
je veux faire part et je veux vivre mon
rêve je je veux faire de la musique et
mes parents m'ont surtout mon papa qui
avait connu les plus grands jazzmen qui
selon lui crever de faim mais mon
conseiller ils m'ont conseillé tous les
deux de suivre une voie plus sécuritaire
pour mon avenir c'est vrai les parents
veulent toujours la sécurité la sécurité
la sécurité à tout prix au prix
d'étouffer les rêves c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'on les aime aussi les parents
jacques brel dit une phrase le monde
sommeil par manque d'imprudence
moi j'ai écouté sage je suis allé j'ai
fait deux ans d'études à la réunion et
je suis allé les poursuivre à
montpellier mais avant de partir mon
regard sur l'art sur la réunion changé
j'avais envie de me remplir de réunion
j'avais envie de boire la réunion alors
j'ai écouté des dizaines de cd de
musique réunionnaise
je suis allé dans les kabars dans les
services camaret en tout cas quelques
uns c'est des endroits on joue le maloya
en rite de communication avec les
esprits et j'ai un jour j'ai entendu
parler d'un concert de danyel waro un
autre pilier du maloya
je connaissais que de nom j'y suis allé
et là ça a été une révélation
ça a été un boom je suis tombé amoureux
du maloya
ce soir là danyel waro mathis ensemble
parler parce qu'on sait pas parler mais
il n'a dit toi tu vis à la réunion mais
en vois tu la beauté en comprends-tu
toute la profondeur
c'était clair que non alors je suis
retourné chez moi et j'ai pris cet
instrument que firmin viry m'avait
offert le caillou et j'ai su créer cet
instrument je les secouer jusqu à savoir
en jouer
résout à papa la donne à main en bois
malbar et dalle on l'avait fait poulies
côté trois-mâts vote attention dalons
timité connais pas porter attention
dalons et en bout elle arrête là tefal
et sauf ali polidori son cri
emma passe des anges où elle à paris
sans murs aux arts aux la ravine amour
aux as tu prétends pas à mme rosa faux
ou mazini samir aux un rose maloya
qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'il s'est
passé à montpellier la musique m'a
rattrapé rattraper tellement qu'une
semaine avant de passer un examen final
dans le sport j'étais à berlin avec mon
groupe graines cm et je faisais un
concert maman calme-toi
de retour à la réunion
j'étais devenu moniteur de tennis pour
subvenir à mes besoins parce que c'est
aussi une passion et je j'avais même la
musique à côté
j'avais gagné quelques prix du monde de
la musique des professionnels qui qui me
réconfortait qui me disait vas-y fais-le
pas mais j'avais toujours peur peur de
sortir de ma zone de confort peur de
sortir de ma zone de sécurité
la revoilà et un jour mon père a fait un
avc un accident accident vasculaire
cérébral et en allant à l'hôpital enfin
à l'hôpital en enlevant son masque à
oxygène il me dit carlo fait de la
musique fait ce que tu aimes parce que
toi aussi un jour tu auras les pieds
froids
il a toujours une humour un peu grinçant
mon père
donc moi ça a été mon deuxième déclic le
maloya aujourd'hui à travers ma
formation graines semées à donner un
sens à ma vie n'a permis de voyager de
rencontrer des gens de rencontrer des
cultures et surtout de partager la
culture et l'identité réunionnaise c'est
très important pour moi parce que c'est
à travers le malien qu'une grande partie
de la culture et l'identité réunionnaise
a survécu et survit encore actuellement
alors à l'image de ces hommes comme
l'ami de mon père qui m'a offert le
tambour comme daniel waro firmin viry et
tous les autres qui vont donner l'amour
de la réunion mais moi j'essaie à mon
tour de transmettre ce qu'on m'a offert
alors je travaille avec les enfants ont
fait des ateliers maloya où on explique
comment construit des instruments et
puis comment on joue de ces instruments
je suis aussi des ateliers langue créole
comme on écrit même si ya pas de graphie
imposé mais comment on écrit en suivant
une graphie c'est assez marrant parce
que à la réunion les enfants quand ils
veulent bien parler faire de la poésie
alors il parle en français et puis quand
ils veulent s'insulter ce mook athées se
moquer de l'ail parlant créole
nous essayons de casser ces caricatures
là parce que dans les deux langues
nous pouvons toucher la profondeur le
maloya et la musique me permet aussi
actuellement de m'engager par rapport à
des sujets qui me touchent
particulièrement
comme celui de l'écologie tout le monde
s'accorde à dire que la réunion c'est un
joyau de la nature
c'est vrai mais le béton cool
de plus en plus comme partout chaque
année de nouvelles routes
on va peut-être même faire une route
dans la mer pour arriver à saint denis
plus vite assister aux conférences ted
donc j'ai fait
donc j'ai fait ce rêve timar hic c'est
un gramoune qui vit à côté de chez moi
en haut du tampon à brac benneteau ce
gramoune un rêve que la réunion comme le
dit sénèque bascule dans une sobriété
heureuse que la réunion sorte de cette
frénésie du béton qui m'a ricky ray
e-rev la réunion timar ic ir licence
d'un béton
tim à ricky ray
il rêve la réunion timar ic i really
saut de béton dit marie qui rêve ni des
canes la terre sauf forfait qayyum
pourra vivre de mon coeur tu mari qui
rêve ni des tac la langue pour nous
bandent mammary maloya décembre si marie
curel il rêve la réunion
timar ic ir est lisse autant béton
tu m'as ricky ray ni des canes la terre
pour nous plante de riz pour nous
plaindre au grain
même sans samarie pour new game osé et
où les psys clouté sens afin de
l'engrais du mari qui lève la obra quant
aux outils marie-claire vaut son amour
du mari qui l'aide d'une fine azla plis
okip son carreau ti piment aux oiseaux
si marie qui rêvent même si ligety
même si soleil la peau fera tina ly ty
marie queyrel e-rev la réunion
ti marieke guehrer lissot de béton
si marie qui ravirait il rêve la réunion
i really really mari qu ils raviraient
leeson béton l'ireb les rêves dit marie
qui rêvent lire et relire elle lit rêve
la réunion les rêves des rêves
timar ic i really saute de béton
ma rencontre avec le maloya fut une
rencontre avec une grande partie de moi
même mais du singulier
nous touchons aussi l'universel et
j'entends encore trop souvent ces
discours qui n'ont pas lieu d'être ni à
la réunion ni ailleurs oui la réunion la
culture réunionnaise la rényon hésiter
et magnifique pour celui qui sait
regarder pour celui qui a envie de
découvrir
j'invite d'ailleurs tous les réunionnais
à partager leur identité à partager leur
culture à partager leur musique en
parlant du maloya
je parle aussi de toutes ces choses de
toutes ces ethnies de toutes ces
couleurs de tous ces regards de tous et
peuvent de toutes ces différences que
l'on juge que l'on caricature sans
connaître réellement sans avoir fait le
premier pas celui de la découverte
respectueuse celui de l' envie de
partage en réunionnais une phrase dit
ceci la piété pini donnent bon heureuse
il y à des buissons d'épineux qui donne
de belles roses merci